welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show podcast the YouTube channel
etc etc you could find me just about
anywhere you may go to the Benjamin
Dixon show com register for my
newsletter why I break down the issues
in three bullet points I give you
critical insights in three bullet points
it's called to the point and so now
let's get to the point Bob Woodward one
half of the Woodward and Bernstein duo
that broke the Watergate story that
eventually brought down Richard Nixon he
has a new book out that has the
president of the United States furious
the new book is entitled fear the Trump
are a rather fear Trump in the White
House now I you if you know anything
about journalism you know who Bob
Woodward is and you know his credibility
and since 1971 since he broke the story
of the Watergate scandal he has
consistently been referred to as one of
the most consistent and trustworthy
journalists with the high the utmost the
highest level of journalistic integrity
this doesn't mean that he can't make a
mistake but I would definitely say he
has more - more incentive to protect the
reputation that has made his entire
career than anything else
I start with that because some of the
allegations that are coming out of this
book are what we would expect from
Donald Trump yet they are still
unbelievable and I want to go through a
couple of the topics that are some of
the key things that are addressed in the
book according to the Washington Post
who broke the story on yesterday quote a
central theme of the book is the
stealthy imaginations used by those in
Trump's inner sanctum to try to control
his impulses and prevent disasters both
for the president personally and for the
nation he was elected to lead Woodward
describes and an administrative coup
d'etat and a nervous breakdown of the
executive branch with senior aides
conspiring to pluck official papers from
the president's desk so that he couldn't
see or sign them so in other words the
people around Donald Trump are pulling
every stunt they possibly can to prevent
a disaster one of those disasters is a
personal disaster for Donald Trump
Donald Trump's attorney John Dowd said
this our rather this is what Bob
Woodward reported he said quote John
Dowd has convinced was convinced that
President Trump would be would commit
perjury if he talked to Special Counsel
Robert as mulleted so on January 27th
the president's then personal attorney
staged a practice session to try to make
his point in the White House residence
Dowd peppered Trump with questions about
Russia the Russia investigation
provoking stumbles contradictions and
lies and to the president eventually
lost his cool saying quote this this
thing is a goddamn hoax Trump
interrupted at the start of a 30-minute
rant that finished with him saying I
don't really want to testify Wow
it gets worse here's another quote from
the Washington Post who broke the story
about Donald Trump's cluelessness with
regard to why we are in South Korea
quote at a National Security Council
meeting on January 19th Trump
disregarded the significance of the
massive US military presence presence on
the North Dakota Korean Peninsula
including a special intelligence
operation that allows the United States
to detect a North Korean missile launch
in seven seconds versus 15 minutes from
Alaska according to Woodward Trump
questioned why the government was
spending resources in the region at all
in this line right here something he
said Madison this we're doing this in
order to prevent World War 3
defense secretary Jim mattis told him
after Trump left the meeting Woodward
recounts mattis was particularly
exasperated and alarmed telling close
associates that the president acted like
and had the understanding of a fifth or
sixth grader again these are not things
that are surprising because this Donald
Trump but it they're still shocking at
the
at the level of ignorance that the
president genuinely operates in and to
the terrifying notion that this is the
man who is in charge of our nation and
is in charge of our nuclear arsenal
here's something that you know if you if
you talk about things that actually
matter substantively it's strange
because the substance of things the true
things that would disqualify Donald
Trump probably won't register with the
American public because it's all baked
into the system we know Donald Trump as
a [ __ ] but this next thing is something
that actually could hurt Donald Trump
politically his opinion and what he said
allegedly said according to the book
about Jeff Sessions quote Trump called
sessions a trader for recusing himself
from overseeing the Russian
investigation
Woodward writes mocking sessions accent
Trump added this guy is mentally
[ __ ] he's this dumb southerner he
couldn't even be a one-person country
lawyer down in Alabama
now again his insult of Jeff Sessions I
don't really care about the Keebler
clansmen as I refer to him he doesn't
doesn't need to be in office but this is
this is low-hanging fruit this is not as
substantive as the other issues however
this may be the one that resonates with
his evangelical southern base they
probably will just reject it and pretend
like oh this is all these are all lies
and fabrications but deep in their their
heart they absolutely know this is
Donald Trump's true opinion of people
from the south and his opinion of Jeff
Sessions now here's one that I think
again doesn't surprise me but absolutely
shows who Donald Trump really is this is
what he said with regard to the
Charlottesville riot and his subsequent
his his condemnation of Nazis that he
reluctantly gave he said quote Trump was
sharply criticized for initially saying
that both sides were to blame at the
urging of advisers he then condemned
white supremacist and neo-nazis but
almost immediately told aides that was
the biggest
Epping mistake I've made and the worst
speech I've ever given according to
Woodward's account I mean we talk about
this all the time Donald Trump is the
white supremacist in chief he
understands I mean he's a [ __ ] in many
ways
but he understands his support base he
if he doesn't if Donald Trump isn't a
student anything else it's who elected
him it's in understanding who elected
him he understands who his core support
group is and this demonstrates that he
is fully aware that he is supported by
neo-nazis white supremacists and white
nationalists across this country and
that's why he hated this and this is why
he said and keep in mind somebody died
someone died in charlottesville as a
result of these neo-nazis in these
fascists but that didn't matter to
Donald Trump he said that this was the
biggest effin mistake he's ever made
this is genuinely who Donald Trump is
Donald J Trump is